>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Robert Newlen: Our line
up of distinguished authors
will discuss a whole range
of topics related to
life in the 21st century.
And I want to just
mention these authors
because it's just a
distinguished line up.
It's just really for the
National Book Festival,
an Embarrassment of Riches.
We have Angela J. Davis.
Yes.
[ Applause ]
Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor.
Jabari Asim--
[ Applause ]
-- who is quickly finishing
his email before the talk.
Just kidding.
Anne-Marie Slaughter, Alejandro
Danois, James McBride, Dian Rehm,
Suzanne Jacoby and Jeffrey
Toobin, so they're all going
to be appearing here today.
And I hope you will get to see them.
Also I want to make special notice
of one author, Jo Ann Jenkins,
who is the current CEO of the
AARP and a former senior manager
at the Library of Congress.
Jo Ann and AARP are
long time supporters
of the National Book Festival.
And I really want to extend
my gratitude to her and AARP
for their continued support.
I think she'll enjoy her
talk about disruptive aging.
I've turned 63 in just
a couple more months.
And I've heard Jo Ann speak.
And a lot of the things
she was talking
about really rang through for me.
So I hope you get to see her.
But it's now my pleasure to
tell you about today's program,
which is a panel discussion
about contemporary issues
in African-American lives.
It is my pleasure to introduce
the first of three panelists
for this discussion, Jabari Asim,
who is an author, poet, playwright
and associate professor of
writing literature and publishing
at Emerson College in
Boston Massachusetts
where he directs the MFA
Creative Writing Program.
He's also the executive
editor of the crisis.
Please welcome Jabari Asim
and our panelists today.
And thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Jabari Asim: Thank you, Robert.
Good afternoon.
I like to welcome you
to this discussion.
As Robert says the first
to take place today
on a temporary life stage here
at the National Book Festival
is my great privilege to be
in conversation with two insightful
authors whose work has obvious
developments to many of
the events taking place
in the country at this time.
We convene following the police
killings of Terence Crutcher,
Keith Lamont Scott, which follows so
many similar deaths of women and men
of color across the nation.
They are events that have prompted
many cannot only question the
justice system but also the words
of the great Fannie Lou
Hamer to question America.
I'll keep the introduction
short because you can read more
in the festival brochure, but
with me is Angela J. Davis,
professor of law at American
University, Washington College
of Law and the author
of "Arbitrary Justice;
The Power of the American
Prosecutor."
She's an expert in
criminal law and procedure
and researches prosecutorial
power and racism
in the criminal justice system.
Her forthcoming book, "Policing
the Black Man" will be available
Pantheon next year.
We're joined by Keeanga-Yamahtta
Taylor, an assistant professor
in Princeton University Center
for African-American studies.
Her research often examines
race and public policy.
Her book from Black Lives Matter to
Black Liberation is an examination
of history, politics
and the development
of the social movement Black
Lives Matter in response
to police violence
in the United States.
We're going to talk a little bit
among ourselves before welcoming
questions from the audience
later in the product.
We don't have a lot of
time, so I'll dive right in.
Keeanga, thank you for your book.
There was as a-ha moment for me
on nearly every page especially
when you encourage me to
think about connections
between local developments and
national movements and to think
about contemporary
moments within the context
of a much longer historical
structure.
You've written that when your
publisher first encouraged you
to write this book.
You declined.
I'm very glad that
you eventually agreed,
but I'm curious why
you hesitated at first.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: There
were probably two main reasons.
One is I had just moved
across the country
from Chicago to Philadelphia.
I teach at Princeton University.
And, you know, it was a fairly
significant transition for me.
And I felt like I was trying to
get acclimated to a new place,
a new situation and didn't have
time to write a book especially
because I was supposed to
be writing another book,
the book that I'm writing now.
So-- And then the second one
is probably more relevant,
which is that it's difficult
to write about something
that is unfolding that
you're in the midst
of to essentially write
about a moving target.
And so, I-- my reluctance was
because things seem to be changing
so rapidly because we had
already gone from a movement--
a local movement tightly
bound to events and Ferguson
from August 2014 until December.
And in December of 2014, I don't
know if people will remember,
we really went from a
locally focused struggle
to have a police officer indicted
in Ferguson to a national movement
that was sort of propelled
by then the killing of young,
Tamir Rice in Cleveland,
Tanisha Anderson in Cleveland,
I think a couple of weeks
before Tamir Rice was killed.
And then Eric Garner,
who hundreds of thousands
of people had seen choked to death
by New York City police officers the
month before Mike Brown was killed.
In Ferguson the officer
who ultimately killed Eric
Garner was also not indicted,
somewhere the beginning of December.
And so, it all of a sudden
turned into a national phenomenon
with marches and demonstrations
across the country.
And so, I had so many things
in my head that I wanted to--
I was thinking about
that I wanted to say
that I essentially took
a weekend to decide
if I could actually write the book.
And I sat down at a coffee shop and
I think I wrote eight or 9000 words
in four or five hours,
all of which I could use.
And so that was like
I have things to say.
I can write this book.
And so I did.
>> Jabari Asim: I was glad you did.
Angela you served many
years as a public defender,
how much do that direct experience
figure into this book as well
as the book you're working
on, "Policing the Black Man."
And I also wonder if you might
comment on what Keeanga talked
about trying to almost keep
pace with the headlines
as you work on something like that.
>> Angela J. Davis: Yes.
Yes absolutely.
Well, my years at the DC Public
Defender Service had everything
to do with that book
because I worked
at the DC Public Defender
Service for a dozen years.
And one of the things that
there were a lot of things
that trouble me because, you know,
it's all about the criminal
justice system and its flaws,
but the thing that troubled me
the most was this incredible power
and discretion that
prosecutors have.
I saw them doing all kinds
of things that were--
if they didn't qualify
as prosecutorial misconduct,
they were unfair.
They created results
that were simply unfair,
people similarly situation people,
people who committed the same crimes
allegedly being treated differently.
And the difference seemed
to be race and/or class.
And they were held
accountable for it.
It didn't seem to be a mechanism
for holding them accountable.
And I-- didn't seem right,
we're in a democracy, right?
We hold those accountable
to whom we grant power.
And these were the most
powerful individuals
in the criminal justice system.
And I just thought how can this be?
So when I did join the academy,
I started researching it,
writing articles and then
finally thought, I get more to say
about this, you know, and
wanted to do this book.
So it had every influence on me.
And as far as I can so relate to
what Keeanga is saying about trying
to keep up with the headlines
in terms of the book I'm working
on now, which is an anthology.
I have a number of
contributing editors,
but it's about policing
the black man.
Of course, it came out of these
killings of unarmed black men
and women throughout the country.
And, you know, we'll never
finish writing that book it seems
because every single day
there's another killing.
And it's just unfathomable.
>> Jabari Asim: So your description
of there being different punishment
for different types of defendants
makes me think about your book
in which you use the phase
double standard of justice
in which you deliberately eco
the Kerner Commission's language.
This notion of a double standard
of justice challenges our tendency
to think of law and order
is something inherently good
or designed in our best interest.
Could you tell us more about
the meaning of double standard
of justice as you see it?
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: Sure.
I think the main thing
that I wanted to--
well, there are two things I
wanted to draw attention to,
one is I use the phrase
from the Kerner Commission,
which people don't know.
In the aftermath of the uprisings
in the 1960s from 1963 at Birmingham
to the rebellions after the
assassination of Martin Luther King
in April of 1968, actually
prior to the king uprisings,
Lyndon Johnson had paneled a
commission to investigate the causes
of the rebellions, which, you know,
fairly significant but involved
over 500,000 African-Americans
and more than more
than 200 cities in
the United States.
And so, they came up with
a list several factors
that contributed to these uprisings.
And one of them had to
do with police brutality.
And they referred to the
double standard of justice.
Meaning essentially that there is--
appears to be one standard of
justice for one group of people
in the United States and
then a separate standard
for African-Americans in particular,
though you could talk about the ways
in which non white people seem
to get treated differently,
consistently throughout the
American criminal justice system.
And so, some of these involve just
looking at disparities, you know,
you look at the number of black
people in the US, which is somewhere
between 12 and 13% of the
population and yet black people make
up almost half of the
people in prison,
almost half of the
people on death row.
In every sort of category
that you go
through through the
criminal justice system,
there is a grotesque
overrepresentation of black people
in the criminal justice system.
And so I wanted to draw attention
to that for obvious reasons
in the context of the emergence of
this Black Lives Matter movement
and investigate why that is.
Why is there-- this
almost unbroken continuity
of racial discriminatory
approaches to policing from the time
of emancipation
for African-Americans
to the current moment?
And so there were many
things that I say about that,
which cause into question the
entire institution of policing is
to whether or not it's actually
about policing and ending crime
or whether or not it's
about something else
that has absolutely
nothing to do with crime.
And just, you know, as one
example of that, you look at a city
like Chicago, which is obviously
struggling quite a bit with violence
and crime that has been
highlighted in the mass media.
But if you just look at two
things that have transpired
in the last three months in Chicago,
they have fired 1000 teachers
and two days ago, Rahm
Emanuel pledged
to hire 1000 police officers.
When it came to teachers,
we were told that oh there's a
budget crisis, we can't afford this,
you know, put 40 kids in a
classroom, do whatever you have
to do to make the situation work.
When it comes to hiring
police officers,
which will cost a $135 million, the
Mayor has said that he will turn
over every stone to come up with
money necessary to hire the police.
And so we have to put those
to realities together.
And when they don't fit together,
we have to ask is policing really
about protecting and
preserving law and order
or is it about something else?
And what is it that
something else that I'm--
I think is important to talk
about that gets what is meant
by there being two standards
of justice in the country?
>> Jabari Asim: And
related to that, Angela,
the Black Lives Matter movement
has brought attention to the role
of prosecutors, it's a high
profile case, and so the behavior
of prosecutors has sort of
entered the public conversation
in a way that it hasn't often.
We talked about Robert McCulloch
following the killing of Mike Brown,
in Ferguson Anita is now out of
office but following the killing
of Laquan McDonald in Chicago and
Marilyn Mosby following the killings
of Freddie Gray in Baltimore.
Now your book addresses among other
things what you call discretionary
decision making on the
part of prosecutors.
Can you tell us something
about that within the context
of the movement for black lives?
>> Angela J. Davis: Sure.
So that's one of the
things that I've noted
that I found so interesting.
I mean, what I've been trying
to do is make people pay
attention to prosecutors.
I mean, of course, we need
to pay attention to cops
and there's been a lot of attention
paid to them unfortunately things
that gotten better, they
seem to be getting worst.
But very few people pay attention
to the prosecutor, right,
that when they are the
most powerful individual
in our criminal justice system, the
cop can stop a person on the street,
can arrest them, can harass
them and that's awful,
but they can only bring the
person to the court house door.
They do not make the decision
about whether that person stays
in the system, the prosecutor does.
The prosecutor and the
prosecutor alone decides whether
to charge the person.
They don't have to charge them if
they don't want to, we know that.
Now, when we see them not
charging cops, they decided what
to charge the person with.
And so, that discretion and it's
totally up to their discretion
to do so, them and them alone.
That is an incredible power
that prosecutors have.
And I don't think people have been
paying too much attention to it,
but one of the things that
has happened since all
of these killings of-- on black men
have come to light and, of course,
you're Keeanga they've been
going on since slavery,
but we didn't have cell phone
cameras back then so no one believed
that what happened happened.
And now we see it happening.
But now people are starting to pay
attention because I think, well,
wait a minute-- why-- I just
saw this cop murdered this man
with my eyes.
I saw Eric Garner being choked
to death with my two eyes.
And the prosecutor did
not charge the cop.
And so now, people
are paying attention
to this powerful person,
the prosecutor.
And they need to pay attention
because most the prosecutors,
the vast majority of
them on the state
and local level are
elected officials.
And their names are
on the ballot folks.
And people don't pay
attention to those racist.
A lot of the times-- most of the
times they ran unopposed but even
when they do run against
other people, they don't talk
about what they do behind closed
doors, they're charging decisions,
they're plea-bargain decisions,
most people aren't even
familiar with those terms.
They went on "I'm tough on crime"
and their opponent says
"I'm tougher on crime."
And that's all they say about what
they do, but now people are starting
to pay attention to what they do
and started pay attention to racism.
And one last thing I'll
say before you move
on is Anita Alvarez
is a prime example.
So Anita Alvarez was the
prosecutor in Chicago
and people didn't really pay
attention to what she was doing,
but then when Laquan McDonald was
killed and there was a videotape
that was not released and she said
on that indicted, didn't move forth
and it wasn't until a judge
ordered a release of that videotape
and we could see what
actually happened
that she didn't decide
to charge that cop.
I firmly believe she
never would have
if that videotape hadn't come out.
The interesting thing about her
though is that when that happened,
the media started to
investigate her background.
And is turns out, she was one
of the worst prosecutors ever
because she had engaged
in tremendous amounts
of prosecutorial misconduct
throughout her 10-year
as a prosecutor.
No one know about that, no one
was paying attention to it.
And, of course, she was voted
out because people
started paying attention
and now Kim Foxx is the prosecutor.
And then finally Marilyn Mosby
when you see the different way
that she came in there and
she brought those indictments
in the Freddie Gray case, but
we see what happened, right?
No convictions.
Absolutely no convictions, I'm
not saying that sort of fault,
but they chose not
to have a jury trial.
And, of course, they were acquitted.
I will say this, I-- in
terms of what prosecutors do,
we need to pay attention not only
to whether they're indicting cops,
that's so important, we
need to pay attention
to what are they doing every
day with the lives of black
and brown people who
they are charging.
They're not charging cops but
they are steadily charging black
and brown people over pay things.
And I will say including
my sister Marilyn Mosby,
Baltimore has most terrible,
some of the most terrible racial
disparities in the country.
And so, I would like to talk
to her about maybe, you know,
I'm glad she moved on those cops.
But, you know, why are so many black
and brown people being locked up,
being charged in Baltimore over
petty things and locked up?
She has the power to change that.
And I hope that she will.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor:
Do you think her movement
on that though is indicative
about the moment
because in my opinion the only
reason why she moved on that is
because there is an
uprising in Baltimore
and the political establishment had
to do something to retain some level
of legitimacy, because I think
that you can have a spectrum
for where people felt--
who are prosecutors on it.
So you have Draconian [phonetic]
law and order prosecutor,
someone like Anita Alvarez and that
woman in Florida, what Angela--
>> Angela J. Davis:
Angela-- we share a name.
Corey.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: Yes.
OK. So you have that on
one end of the spectrum
and then people will
point to Maryland,
Mosby on the other
end of the spectrum.
But what gets lost in that
I think is, what is the job
of the prosecutor, which
is to prosecute people.
And so, for Mosby in Baltimore even
though she was compelled I think
because of the uprising to press
charges against six police officers
in Baltimore, three weeks
before Freddie Gray was picked
up by the police, she
individually put out a memo
that basically said she wanted more
eyes in hands on deck on the corner
that Freddie Gray was picked
up, which police interpreted
or at least-- you know,
they set, they interpreted
as a direct order to
produce more arrests.
And this is part of the
politicization of policing and law
and order in cities in the
first place, which is so much
of it is driven by arrest rates.
How many people can you arrest
which becomes political father for--
is proof that you're
being tough on crime.
And watching-- using
that to determine whether the
crime rate is rising or falling
in a very political way not a
way that is substantive in terms
of are we transforming the quality
of people's lives in this community
by actually ending crime through the
creation of good jobs, good schools
and creating some sense
of community, not that
but tracking the rise and fall
of arrest rates as a way to turn
into a campaign slogan that
you are either tough on crime
or you're opponent isn't
as tough as you are.
And so, there's a whole logic
that is generated among elected
officials including prosecutors
that has nothing to do with
actually improving the neighborhoods
and communities that people live in.
But it's all about how you
can turn these situations
into political capital
and it's a problem.
>> Jabari Asim: And related to
that there doesn't appear to be--
since we-- the spotlight, the player
of the spotlight tends to move away
from the prosecutor except
for doing electro campaigns.
It doesn't seem to
be much transparency
in terms of how they operate.
And so, two factors there is the
only way to discipline prosecutors
by voting them out of office.
And you've mentioned in your
book the role of bar associations
and agencies within the
profession that ostensibly govern
or somehow overlooking some process.
What can we-- what can we do?
Is voting them out the only
recourse I guess is what I'm asking?
>> Angela J. Davis: Yeah.
So, you just stressed something
you said about transparent.
There's no transparency, right?
So the most important decisions they
make out of that charging decision
and the plea bargain decision.
By the way, people think, you know,
there are all these trials going
on because they're watching
law and order on TV.
There are not a lot
of trials going on.
Ninety-five percent of all
criminal cases are resolved
by way of a guilty plea, 95%.
It's higher in some
jurisdictions, right?
That's all on that issue.
But they control that too?
They control the plea bargaining,
they control who gets to plea,
what the plea is, whether
the person is going
to be charged, whether they're not.
There are a lot of people
who are committing crimes
who are not being charged at all.
We don't know that
because [inaudible].
We find that out when the media
investigates a certain case
and that, oh now we know.
But there's no way
for us to know that.
That's so undemocratic, right?
I mean, that's not what democracy
is supposed to be about, right?
So I just want to stress that
point first and foremost.
What can we do about it?
So elections.
As I said before, you know,
most state in local prosecutors
are elected officials.
The problem is that often
times when you go to vote,
there's often one name there because
people don't challenge prosecutors.
They-- some of them serve for
a decade, so there's term limit
and as hard as we know to run for
office because it requires money.
So, Obama called for example in
Ferguson, there was a black woman
who actually challenged him
and she got nowhere, you know,
she didn't have backing, he was
powerful in combat, you know,
in terms of the population.
They are African-Americans, you
know, they're in the minority
in that particular county.
So it's hard to vote them
out, but it can happen,
[inaudible], you know who got out.
And it's interesting
because I think she can--
and Anita Alvarez was unseated
in Chicago I think largely
because of the spotlight, national
spotlight coming on her similarly
to the prosecutor in
Staten Island who failed
to prosecute the cop
who killed Eric Garner.
He was voted out.
And largely people think
because of the spotlight.
So it's interesting how
that's had an impact.
But folks, we need to
pay attention and vote
and the things you do is
question your prosecutors.
I may ask them questions
when these things happen.
Call them up.
They're elected officials
just like everybody else.
They have to be elected.
You mentioned bar association.
So another way to deal with
prosecutors who are misbehaving
and engaging in this
conduct is bar council.
So, people may remember the
Duke lacrosse case years ago,
the prosecutor there Mike Nifong
was disbarred because of his--
because of what happened in that
case and his failure to turn
over exculpatory evidence.
But, you know, who the defendants
where they were wealthy
white lacrosse players
who could afford fancy lawyers who
were able to investigate and go
through all of it, DNA
complicated evidence and discover.
Oh the prosecutor didn't
turn this over.
And so therefore, we're going
to refer him to bar council.
So bar council is a body in every
state, which disciplines lawyers
when they valuate the rules
of professional conduct.
They can disbar them, they
can suspend them and so on.
Prosecutors almost never, ever,
ever disbarred for anything.
They're rarely referred.
Mike Nifong was in fact the
first prosecutor I was aware
of who was disbarred for the--
his failure to turn over
exculpatory evidence,
which is a violation of the rules.
I can't tell you the number of
cases I had as public defender
where prosecutors fail to
turnover exculpatory evidence.
There are many high profile case
where people have gone in death row
because prosecutors have
failed to turn it over.
Were those prosecutors disbarred?
No. Were they even
referred to bar council?
No, nothing happened to that money
of them went on to become judges,
being-- went on to become greater
things, but, you know, the Nifong--
the lacrosse players had the power
to hit the stature and like, oh no.
You know, they had
spent a day in jail.
I mean nothing happened to them
yet that prosecutor was disbarred.
This just blew my mind
because I was like that's--
well, can I think of the cases
of people like I said almost died
because of something prosecutor do
and those prosecutors
did not suffer anything.
I am writing.
In fact, just wrote an article
called the Prosecutor's Ethical Duty
to en masse incarceration
which I know sounds crazy
but I think they have ethical
duty to en masse incarceration.
And I used--
[ Applause ]
-- Thank you.
Because we have a crisis,
we have 2.2 million people
in prisons, in jails.
You know, these reports of black
and brown people, it's unfair.
And they have the power
to stop that.
They have the power to end
it in many different way.
And so-- and I used the rules
and there are rules that talk
about their ethical duty
to be ministers of justice
and to administer justice.
This is not just as what
they're doing here, it's not.
So I'm making argument that
they have an ethical duty.
The problem with the rules though,
Jabari, is that the rules that apply
to prosecutors are so weak, right?
So there's so many
things prosecutors do
that I think are unfair
and unethical,
that are not under the rules.
So we need to change
the rules and we need
to use the rules that
we have to refer.
Anybody can refer someone
a bar council.
We don't have to be a lawyer.
If they are aware of misconduct,
the problem is what you said
and I'll stop here,
before lack of transparency
to discover what they're doing
in the first place,
right, is difficult.
So you can't refer them if you
don't know about their doing.
So, I mean I think that's a problem.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: It is
the double standard of justice.
>> Angela J. Davis: Yes, indeed.
>> Jabari Asim: Keeanga, I wanted
to return to a point you made
about that corner on which
Freddie Gray was arrested
and he initially attracted
the attention
of the police by making eye contact.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: Yes.
>> Jabari Asim: And that
made me think of a phrase.
You have a number of phrases that
resonated with me and your book.
One of them you talk about
criminalization creep
in which this-- the notion of what
is criminal behavior continues
to expand so that more and more
people are caught in the net.
Can you talk more about that?
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: Sure.
It's amazing that in a country that
purports to be for small government,
liberty, not intrusive, you know,
state that if you look at the sort
of growing lists of actions
that are becoming crimes,
it's a complete front to that
logic so that in many cities now,
it's a crime to sit on the sidewalk,
it's a crime to sleep in your car.
It's a crime to sleep
outside in public in general.
It's a crime to ask for
money to beg for money.
And there's a growing list of
what may perhaps be construed
as a nuisance have been
transformed into criminal behavior.
And the problem with this is this
approach to the law is manifest.
I mean, there's the constant
invitation for engagement
with the police, which then
creates an entire broader whirlwind
of problems as a result
because one of the things
that we're finding now almost
directly as a result of the uprising
in Ferguson is the way in
which the police in unison
with city government and often
in unison with prosecutors.
Almost act is a kleptocracy,
meaning that they've turned
into official policy
stealing essentially from poor
and working class people
partly as a way
to fill the coffers
of municipalities.
In Ferguson, there was
a direct relationship
which was almost an order for
the police to draw a paycheck,
they had to rely on finding and feed
the black population of the city.
And so, you end up with this
huge portion of the population
in Ferguson with outstanding
warrants based on unpaid fees
for traffic violations,
which makes no sense.
And so, that is part of
the problem with the sort
of growing criminalization of
non criminal offences in the way
that it draws people in to
the criminal justice system
through assortment of fines and
fees that if people can't pay,
that then turn into
criminal offences
that people are actually
are arrested for.
And so, not only are the
police not attending to crime,
but there are also
deepening poverty,
they're also raising the
propensity for crime in these--
in the communities that
they are targeting for this.
And this I think has become part of
a larger critique of the movement
in terms of targeting this.
I think one of the things
that we have to focus
on in the movement is this issue of
decriminalization of actually trying
to undue the criminalization of
these non criminal offenses for all
of the complications that
come as a result of it.
>> Jabari Asim: All right.
That leads to a follow
up for both of you.
But while you were talking also,
remember that you mentioned
in the book that there's one
neighboring municipality in Ferguson
that actually rigged
the traffic light,
so the police can turn
it red while cars were
in the middle of the entry section.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: This
was a fundraising technique.
And it's not just some little
podoc [phonetic], you know,
at least remember from the
duke's hazard, you know,
all these tricks to, you know,
get people to run a red light
or run stop signs or
you can give a ticket.
In Chicago in the, you know,
second or third largest city
in the United States, when
they went through implementing,
I think there are more red
light cameras in Chicago
than any other city in the country.
Not only did they, you know,
put red light cameras everywhere
where if you run a red light
it's an automatic $100 fine.
If you don't pay it within
I think 60 days, it doubles.
another 30 days, it triples.
And so you can see how
immediately this is something
that ensnares working
class and poor people,
but they shorten the yellow light.
They shortened it, so that to
raise-- to increase the likelihood,
the people would be, you know,
then running a red light.
So not only are they putting
people's lives at risk
by shortening the red light and,
you know, compelling people to speed
through it, but it's an actual
fundraising scheme by the city
on the box of the people
who can least afford it.
And so, the idea that elected
officials will be using the police
as a way to bridge
financial gaps in the city is
so problematic on so many levels.
Not-- you know, not only
is this not what, you know,
we are told police are supposed
to do, this has nothing to do
with fighting crime,
not even in the least.
But it also creates
an antagonism in terms
of where the police are located,
who it is that they are trying
to ticket, who it is that can
least afford to be indebted over,
you know, parking tickets
and red light tickets
and that sort of thing.
>> Jabari Asim: OK.
Follow up.
I'm going to start with you Angela,
but I'm going to start with a quote
from Keeanga, she wrote,
"You've written
that historically the
vast majority of police
in the United States were
white uneducated working class
and completely consumed
with racism."
And that made me think of the FBI's
own report about the infiltration
of white supremacies in police
departments around the country.
Colin Kaepernick has recently
contended that in some cities,
cosmetologists require
more training than police.
I'm noting all of these
during the time
when the nation's largest police
union has endorsed Donald Trump's
campaign for president.
Within that context becomes hard
to regard community policing
and restoring trust anything
other than skepticism.
Is reformed two gentle concept here.
Should we be thinking of
something more extensive?
>> Angela J. Davis: For
police you talk about?
>> Jabari Asim: Yeah.
>> Angela J. Davis: I think yes.
I mean, the-- the idea of policing
has not been my focus in terms
of coming up with things that
we should do, but I will say--
in other words, there's
not my expertise
about what should we do rather
than the reform we're doing now
but it's clear that whatever this
reform is we're doing now even work.
And so, community policing
means so many different things
and so many different areas.
It certainly is not
anything that has stopped
or in my opinion even reduce
the abuse that police, you know,
rain down on communities of color.
I mean, clearly that it has
not changed that at all.
So, if it is going to be
continued reform, it has to look
like something very
different than what it is now.
So we know the president at this
taskforce on 21st century policing.
And my good friend Tracey
Meares is on that taskforce.
Bryan Stevenson is on.
And they're great people
were on that taskforce.
I mean, I just think-- and I'm,
you know, I hope that there's going
to be some changes
of result of that.
I think the problem is
that, you know, how--
who makes police do
what they do, right?
It gets back to that like the
president can have this taskforce,
but he actually has no direct power
over a local police department.
He cannot make them do anything.
38:05 make them do
unless they file a lawsuit
and do the consent decrees.
And I think those things
are important.
I think they're report that
came out of Ferguson as a result
of justice department's
investigation was
incredibly important.
They just did a similar
report in Baltimore.
Those things are incredibly
important.
But in terms of directly making
police officers behave differently,
I think it has to be a, you know,
I don't even know how this is going
to be done but there has to be a
totally different mindset in change
about what police officers
are supposed to be doing.
I mean, you're right, there's an
old training, require for them
to come in, the background
or what kind
of background checks they're doing.
There's no psychological
testing done on a regular basis.
I think some-- let's
put it this way.
It varies from city to city.
Some do none, some do some.
They don't do them regularly.
So, you know, we see the kind of
people who end up on police forces
and what they are doing to people.
Many of them come out with this
militaristic idea of their policing,
they're there to, you know, control
those communities not to serve them.
I mean, that's the
mindset of so many of them.
And so, how we change
this nationally?
I don't know, because the way
governance work the president can't
come in and fire all the police.
He doesn't have the
power to do that.
So, so much of it is up to these
individual state local entities.
That's why tell people, you know,
most police chiefs are pointed
by the mayor, I mean
all politics is local
and sometimes the most important
politics is local, right,
because your police chief most
likely is appointed by your mayor.
And so, you decide
who that mayor is.
And when you vote, you need
to be asking your mayor.
Who's going to be the police chief?
I want a police chief who will not
going to be out here, you know,
hiring police officers
that are going
to be killing people for no reason.
So it comes right down to that,
you know, to the basics sort
of democratic tenets that we have.
We need to get involved in a
local, in politics and ways to make
that change because there's
no magic bullet that's going
to change this from
around the country.
I hope, I wish if there
is, I hope there is,
but I don't know one, you know?
I think it's that hard work of
getting in there individually
in your communities becoming
active in your communities
and saying you're not going to
have this in your community.
And that involves getting on the
street, it involves demonstrating
but it also involves voting
and being politically active.
>> Jabari Asim: I'm going to ask
that if you want Keeanga
response to that by her book.
>> Angela J. Davis: I'm sorry.
I want her response, so--
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor:
Can I just say really quickly?
>> Angela J. Davis: Please?
>> Jabari Asim: Yes, please, please,
but I also want to encourage people
if you have questions, you
can line up at the microphone.
That was my last question if
you have a question or comment
after Keeanga's response.
Please.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: I just--
I will just say really quickly
because I do want to hear from--
I know we wall want to hear
from the audience that one
of the things I write in my book is
that there has been no golden age
of policing that we can point
to to say here is a model
of what good policing community
relationships look like.
And I think that's important because
we often hear politicians say,
oh we have to rebuild
trust, you know,
between the police
and the community.
And so, what are you talking about?
Because to rebuild trust means
that at some point there was trust
to have been established
in the first place.
And so, at every period you look
at 1992, the Los Angeles uprising,
which in many ways was the sort
of first videotape beating
the police are exonerated.
You look at the 1960s, that
Kerner Commission that I talked
about earlier listed the top
three reasons why there were these
rebellions, successive
rebellions in hundreds of cities
across the United States
over that five-year period.
Poverty and unemployment,
substandard housing,
police brutality.
1951, contingent of activist
in the United States went
to present a petition
to the United States.
They called themselves
We Charge Genocide.
It was all about police
violence and abuse.
The first modern urban uprising
in the United States involving a
predominantly black population,
Harlem 1935.
Why? The police killed a
15-year-old boy and, you know,
outside of a shop in
the neighborhood.
And so, there is no point at which
we can talk about good policing
as a model, which for me
raises all sorts of questions
about the institution
of policing itself
and whether it is actually
setup an existent way
to do what we are constantly
told that it is supposed to do.
[ Applause ]
>> Jabari Asim: We
have a number of people
and very little time
to accommodate that.
Let's start over there
and then we'll alternate
from microphone to microphone.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta
Taylor: And we'll be quick.
>> Hello? OK.
Thank you both for this
very important discussion.
And as a young attorney,
I'm particularly glad
that you have talked so much
about prosecutorial discretion
and the role that plays in
the criminal justice system.
And you mentioned so much about the
role of voting in local elections.
Yeah. We have so many state laws
that disenfranchise many black
and brown people particularly
those who were brought
into the criminal justice system
on their perhaps questionable
circumstances
and now lost their right to vote.
Can you comment on how
that particular phenomenon
if you will dovetails with
this entire discussion
that you had so far?
Thank you.
>> Angela J. Davis: So I'm going
to put my friend Nicole Porter
on this-- raise your hand
Nicole, raise your hand higher.
Nicole is at the Sentencing Project,
which is a wonderful
organization here
in the District of Columbia and--
[ Applause ]
-- and the citizen
probably does great work
around felony disenfranchisement.
And in fact, there are many states
where people actually
do have the right
to vote even they have
a felony conviction.
And there's a lot of information
on their website about that.
So I think, you know, the--
that is a huge problem.
In fact, there's so many people have
lost their right to vote as a result
of that, but there are changes
going on in many states around,
then there's a lot of action around
changing that including right
in the commonwealth of Virginia,
although what the government
did there is being challenged.
But I think that people
may have the right to vote
if they have a conviction.
They may still have
the right to vote,
they need to research
that to find out.
So I'm going to direct folks to the
Sentencing Project's website and go
to Nicole afterwards and
she'll tell you all about that.
But I think that's a great point,
so many people have lost their right
to vote, but many people have their
right and they aren't using it
and so, I'm encouraging
those who do to do so.
>> I'm from North Carolina and as
you know we have a law that's going
in the book October 1st to keep
plea stems out of public view.
And I was wondering if
other states have that law.
If you think other states will
adapt it and is there any basis
which that could get off the books.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor:
Interestingly Missouri I believe
is the only other state right now
that has passed a law.
But basically it says the body
camera footage cannot be released--
will not be released to
the public unless it is
up to the discretion I believe
of either the police or a judge,
which of course undermines the
entire point of the transparency
that was intended with that
legislation in the first place.
I absolutely think that this has the
potential to be a kind of copycat
in other states, which are much more
concerned with what they believe
to be protecting the legitimacy
of their police forces than the,
you know, providing transparency to
what is still a public institution.
People forget when there is a
reluctance to release the names
of police officers who kill
civilians releasing footage
from body cameras.
These are public institutions.
That means that they should be
under the most intense
scrutiny of the public.
And so that is one of the
things that we have to keep
in the forefront of
our protest is not--
you know, this isn't
a moral question,
this is about public servants
having to answer to the taxpayers
who provide their salaries
in the first place.
>> Carlos: Hi.
My name is Carlos.
Thank you for having
this conversation.
I just wanted to make a
comment to draw parallels.
I'm a public school teacher,
worked for seven years
in the parallels of schools.
And the common variable is control.
So we unfortunately law enforcement
control rather than tax schools.
I saw a lot of times that it's
control rather than educating.
So it's that common variable and
how do we change that culture
from the very start, right,
of seeing minorities as people
that we need to get
educated versus control.
And as a result don't grow
up thinking that, you know,
they are a problem for law
enforcement and those students
who were with them as
cops see them as someone
to control versus to protect.
So I just wanted to
make that comment
because those parallels
were just came to mind
as I heard the discussion.
But thank you again
for the discussion.
>> Angela J. Davis: Thank you.
>> Jabari Asim: Thank you.
>> Thank you for the conversation.
I just-- my question
is for professor Davis.
As you know being a public
defender service lawyer,
are prosecutors mostly
are US attorneys
who obviously the US
attorney for the District
of Columbia is appointed
and is not elected.
And similarly all of our judges
in DC superior court are
appointed by the president.
So I know you mentioned bar
council complaints and obvious--
and I think that that's a crucial
way to try to help shine some light
on prosecutorial conduct, but
specifically for those of us
who are district citizens here.
What can we do to try
to hold both our judges
and our prosecutors accountable?
>> Angela J. Davis: Did you say
you're a public defender here in DC?
>> No I said, you're
a public defendant.
[ Laughter ]
Attorney but not a public defender.
>> Angela J. Davis: Yes, I was.
So DC is that strange animal out of
all because it's not a state, right?
And so, the US attorney, which is
a federal prosecutor every state
as a US attorney, one or
more US attorneys, prosecutor
and federal court, but in DC,
the US attorney prosecutes both the
local crimes and the federal crimes.
So you can't-- right.
So they're appointing.
So you can't vote in the US
attorney because they're federal.
So what do you?
Well, you know, that make--
I was talking about how voting is
the mechanism of accountability
for prosecutors, but it doesn't work
because there's no transparency,
but when there's voting it's
hard to pick a good person.
It's even worst when it's
a federal prosecutor.
Technically the way you
do it is you weigh in when
that prosecutor is nominated,
the person is nominated
to be US attorney then you are
supposed to write, you know,
if you had a senator, which
DC doesn't really have one.
But you weigh in that way, right?
You call Illinois homes north or
whoever and you say, you know,
I don't think this person should
be the prosecutor, US attorney.
The problem is the same
as it is everywhere else
because you don't know what
that person has been doing
as a prosecutor because he's
done behind close doors is not a
perfect system.
I don't-- when I tell people
to go vote I'm not saying that's
the magic wand that's going
to solve everything, it's the
mechanism the system that we have.
As far as judges are concerned, I
don't think necessarily the voting
and elected judge is a
good idea either, right,
because that happens
a lot in the south.
They're-- in fact in a lot
of the death penalty stage,
you have judges running for
office who are actually running
on I will make sure we get
more death penalty cases going
through than others that
are running on that.
So a lot of times, you know,
when it comes to judges,
we have a very different function
from prosecutors having
elected judges
and not necessarily
the answer either,
but hank you for your question.
You raised a good point.
>> Hi. I'm currently
a high school student,
a senior at the Landon
School for Boys.
And I'm the President
of MSA and BSU there.
And I was wondering what is
your stunts on reparations
for African-Americans
in the United States?
Do you think it would be beneficial
or it would reduce catalyst
on ongoing political movements
like Black Lives Matter?
And by reparations, I don't
entirely mean economical.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: I
mean, I'm certainly for reparations
for African-Americans because
I think that we see the ways
that legal racism and discrimination
in particular not just in slavery
but very much in the 20th
century continues to impact
and shape black realities.
I think that the author Ta-Nehisi
Coates did us all a great favor
by connecting the struggle around
reparations not just to the issue
of slavery, but to
the contemporary ways
that racial discrimination
constrains black file particularly
by looking at the role of
government in particular
in legislating discriminatory
practices around housing and access
to housing and red lighting.
And in a country where so much
personal wealth is vested in access
to home ownership in the way
that the federal government
in particular work to
exclude black people
from that enterprise
has continued to--
had implications over generations
in a way that people are often able
to obscure the kind of lineages
that exist between slavery.
And who would be the
direct beneficiary today
and I didn't known a
slave and all of that.
Instead of having that debate, let's
talk about how throughout the course
of the 20th century, public policy
has actively undermine black life
chances, black quality of life.
And so in that context, I'm
very much for reparations.
I'm for checks, for public policy
programs, I'm for all sorts
of the creations of all sorts
of programs and institutions
that can substantively
improve the quality
of black life in this country.
>> Jabari Asim: We
have two minutes left.
[ Applause ]
So we probably have time
for one more question.
>> Thank you.
I'm really excited that I
get to ask this question.
And I'm also really excited
to be here the same
week that I Keeanga is.
I'm here from Standing
Rock, North Dakota.
Anyways, I was wondering
Keeanga if-- thank you.
I was wondering if you could speak
on white supremacism inherently
built into our institutions
and your perspective on how we can
achieve liberation when we live
in a wealthy society built
on land theft and genocide
of native Americans then slave and
then exploitation of free labor
of Africans and the
continued oppression
of the entire working class?
>> Jabari Asim: Wow.
>> Angela J. Davis: In two minutes.
>> Sorry. I hope we
can get him asked too.
>> Keeanga-Yamahtta Taylor: I
mean, the one thing I would say
about that, and thank you for
the question, is, you know,
I think we're in this season where
everyone talks about the importance
of voting and supremacy
of voting and all that.
And that's, you know, that's
fine and well, but reality is--
in my opinion that the
greatest substantive changes
that have happened for poor
oppressed and working class people
in this country have come as a
result of struggle and have come
as a result of movements [applause].
And so, we have to have the
perspective of no matter who is
in the White House
because, you know,
Donald Trump is menacing bigoted
billionaire, but then a lot
of what we are talking about
in terms of mass incarceration,
in terms of the racialization
of black people negatively
the architecture was put
in place 20 years ago.
I mean it was put in
place a long time ago,
but the Clinton administration
in the 1990s,
which gave us the crime bill in
1994, which gave us super predators
and which ended welfare 20
years ago on the premise
of a racist contention that black
people were somehow feeding off the
system unequally or unfairly.
It means that both parties are
complicit in what is happening
to foreign working people.
[ Applause ]
And so, it really how we overcome
that depends on the strength
of our organizing and our movements.
And so, the Black Lives
Matter have to connect
up with the undocumented movement
have to connect up with Arabs
and Muslims in the movement against
Islamophobia, have to connect
up with the brothers
and sisters fighting,
the pipeline in South
Dakota, in every other places
around this country to build
a larger more united movement.
And that's how we as ordinary
people advance our cause.
[ Applause ]
>> Angela J. Davis: I--
I have to say one thing,
I agree with everything
that Keeanga has said,
but please don't stay
home on November 8.
And please come out and vote
and let Donald Trump become the
president of the United States.
I'm sorry I had to say that.
Thank you.
>> Jabari Asim: We are
over of our allotted time.
Thank you all very much.
Thank you.
Thanks to our family.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.